have you ever tried shave ice that's
right
shave ice that snowy powdery treat
served around Hawaii some shops even use
homemade flavors extracted straight from
local fruits it's a great antidote to
the heat and humidity so let's say
you're giving me directions to a worthy
shave ice shop here's a map for you I'm
here and the shop is oh right around
here how do I get there
whether or not you're aware of it the
way you answered that question says a
lot about how you've been taught to
speak about directions in your language
take two direction systems cardinal
directions and relative directions if
you're American European or Chinese
cardinal directions are probably second
nature to you you imagine a map with a
fixed north at the top east and west to
the sides and south at the bottom so you
tell me to go north and then east until
I see the storefront there's another way
to get me there you can direct me from
my own point of view instead this gets
called egocentric direction putting
yourself in my shoes you'll tell me to
turn to my left then go forward then
make a right turn and go straight again
until I've arrived so far I'm not really
telling you anything you don't already
know
but you're in Hawaii now and the
language here lets you get around
without these systems the main
directions are mocha towards the
mountains or Makai towards the sea ma
means towards you guys land and caius
sea so the shave ice is mokhov the
library I'm currently Micaiah the
shopping center so I need to walk mauka
to get there
notice that the mocha Makai system isn't
egocentric if you're standing here and
the sea is here but the mountains are
there this way is mocha no matter which
way you turn
it's unlike cardinal directions to north
is north no matter where you are on the
island but Makai and mocha depend on
your current location
so mauka Makai are unique geographical
directions this is one of many unique
quirks I've found in my journeys check
out the playlists for more travel
vignettes on words and places and thank
you for learning with me
you